good morning good afternoon good evening
and thanks for joining the session on
inside bigquery bi engine
i'm vinaya bala subramaniam i'm a
product manager on bigquery
i'm joined by mosha pasmuski who's a
principal engineer in bigquery
so in today's session we're going to
talk about give an overview of what
bigquery bi engine is
why we built it what is the core value
proposition
we talk about next we go into the
internals of bi engine and we spend a
whole bunch of
like rest of the most of the talk in
talking about how bi engine works
in the end we'll have some exciting
demos to showcase how bi engine
handles higher concurrency and then
we'll have madeline from tableau
showcasing a demo of bi engine with
tableau and we'll have kevin from looker
talk about how bi engine works with look
so let's get started
so doing bi on big data is quite
challenging for customers too
so customers today have to manage
multiple data mods around the data
warehouse
extract data manage complex etl pipeline
to connect their bi tools and that
creates additional management overhead
and administration hold
secondly today bi traditional bi
applications are used to extracting data
from the data warehouse creating
olap cubes running lightly jobs to
refresh those tubes
so they end up doing looking at the
dashboard which is
on old data more and more customers are
looking for not only fast and
interactive dashboard but also they're
looking at
more real-time data so that they can get
insights faster and take action
accordingly
and lastly organization as they scale
globally they want to share their
information and insights not only to
internal stakeholders but also
to external partners and customers so it
adds a lot of
additional concurrency requirement for
their bi solutions
these were some of the reasons why we
wanted to build bi engine
if you look at gcp smart analytics
platform we provide
solutions across all the different life
cycles of bi
starting from connecting to multiple
data sources whether it's on-prem
sources or software-as-a-service
endpoints
we can bring in data from multiple
sources into bigquery
and as part of that transformation we
have provided we provide tools
such as cloud data flow to do
transformation and enrichment on your
streaming data
you have cloud data fusion which looks
at traditional etl
style transformation then we have data
proc
for spark and hadoop sort of workflow
once the data is in
bigquery you can create a metadata layer
to discover data
through data catalog you can use cloud
data prep for data wrangling
and then you can connect the data in
bigquery through multiple bi tools
we provide first party bi solutions
looker
data studio and sheets we also have
connectors from
our rich ecosystem of bi partners
including tableau
power bi micro strategy and click exec
but where bi engine is really helpful is
it acts as an acceleration layer between
bigquery
and your bi2 so all of not just
video studio other bi tools can use this
so the overall vision for bigquery bi
engine is to democratize bi
by enabling business analysts to perform
interactive analytics in real time
so today bi tools compromise between
data freshness and speed
so if you want data to be really fast
and interactive it's not fresh
but if you want data to be fresh and
latest data without any scaleness
it's not fast with bigquery bi engine we
don't want to compromise between
freshness and speed we always want to
give you
fresh data and elsewhere always has to
be fast so there are three key
value propositions of bigquery bi ng it
provides sub-second queries
it simplifies the architecture and it
has smart tuning built
let's go into each one to achieve sub
second query bi engine is a column
oriented
in memory execution engine it can scale
horizontally
so as you have more requests coming in
the engine can
load balance that request by making
copies of data in memory
and load balance those requests and
lastly bi engine works with bigquery
streaming so as you're streaming data in
the data is automatically refreshed into
the in-memory tier so you get latest
data
in terms of simplification of
architecture bi engine is built on top
of bigquery storage
so we there's no need to extract data
out of bigquery we automatically move
data
between the storage tier and the memory
tier
and traditional bi tools require you to
create
olap cubes but we do that automatically
for you
that reduces complexity and architecture
and lastly today bi engine is available
to breeder studio but what we are
bringing to market is
bi engine sql api which is integrated
with bigquery api directly
so any of the other bi tools including
looker tableau
power bi click marker strategy etc can
leverage that without having to make
without having to make any change on
their site
and lastly there are smart tuning built
into bi engine so bi engine
has inbuilt cache optimizations which we
do automatically based on your data
and the way you do that is you create a
reservation where you specify the
location you want the reservation to be
specify the size
and automatically behind it takes care
of tuning the data based on your query
patterns
and all of this data which is available
is is available to stackdriver so you
can look at
how much cash is being used how much
memory is being used how much of that is
coming from cash how much it's falling
back to bitcoin
all of this rich information or metrics
is available in
the edge so that was a quick overview of
bi engine now let's go into
how bi engine works in the internals let
me introduce
mosha to you to walk us through that
thank you venai
uh my name is moshop sumansky and i'm
very excited to talk today with you
about the inner workings of bigquery bi
engine
so we start with the high level
architecture of bigquery
and we see three main pieces here on the
left
is storage that's where bigquery stores
all of its data
on the right compute that's where
clearporting is happening
and between them shuffle layer which
facilitates distributed processing
now let's see where bi engine fits into
this picture
we see bi engine is just another feature
of bigquery
it's not a separate product so it works
on top of the same storage same network
same shuffle layer
and it's working run alongside of
bigquery workers
okay well if it's exactly same
architecture
what what makes it possible for bi
engine
to get such dramatic performance
improvements and this is exactly what
we're going to talk about now
so we see there are three big pieces and
all three of them
contribute to the performance of the
query
storage is a disk io time shuffle is a
network iot time
and compute is cpu so what we're going
to do now we'll pick
each one of those three components and
talk
how bi engine makes this time go to zero
okay let's start with the disk io and
this one may seem to be the most
obvious because we just put data in
memory and there is no disk io
and of course it would have been that
simple if we had unlimited memory and if
we can put
all the data into it but of course it's
more complex than that
we'll have to manage and figure out what
to keep in memory and vote only from
disk
and that's where the bi engine memory
manager comes into picture
this is really the most important piece
it's in the heart of the bi engine
so let's see how it works first of all
big query is a column based database
so we only put specific columns into
memory
not the whole table but more than that
we're not pushing
the entire column only putting chunks of
it and it works equally well
with both partition tables and not
partition tables
so even if your table is not partitioned
on time and it keeps data going
multiple years back but you're only
clearing last few days
memory manager will figure it out next
memory manager not only keeps the raw
data it also keeps direct calculations
like intermediate results of
aggregations
and so on also we talked about
how the engine is always fast and always
fresh
so to be always fresh and not to serve
still data
it has very tight integration with
metadata service
it knows exactly when transactions
commit it keeps exactly the same
snapshot
time timestamps as the rest of bigquery
so whenever new data comes in it knows
how to pick it up and merge with
existing data in memory
even when data changes through gml
operations
memory manager knows exactly which parts
of it should be invalidated
and which should not also
memory manager knows how to work with
load balancing
even if you have small table but with a
lot of
querying coming in it may choose to
implicate
same data over multiple machines which
is easy for us to do because bigquery is
distributed database
so this way it will use small memory
but all the queries will still have very
fast response time
because the load will be spread
so you can see it's pretty sophisticated
system
now let's see what kind of control user
have over it
and this control comes in form of bi
reservations
bi reservations are very similar to
classic bigquery reservations
but the currency is memory so you are
buying
memory and not slots or cpu
all the metrics we serve through stack
drivers so the users
can understand how efficiently they are
using the system
for example in this picture you see two
lines
blue one is how much reservation user
bought
and the orange one is how much that was
used
so user can save they bought too much
and there is
too much unused they can lower the
reservation size
and it takes effect immediately
and you know when they see that the
orange start bumping
into blue meaning that you know the
reservation is not enough for the
current workload
user may choose to buy a little bit more
reservation and
you know balance it like that
okay so we covered how the glvs
storage component now let's talk about
compute or cpu
there are many many techniques that we
use to
improve cpu i'll talk about couple of
them
first one is vectorized processing so
what you see on the left is the classic
way how databases
uh deal to their query engine dealt with
square processing
which is called sometimes so iterator or
tuple iterator model
basically it says you know query plan
comes as a tree of
operators and two separators consume one
row all the time
purchase it send to the next operator
takes next row and so on
so this is very general and you know
very well understood model
but it's not the best one especially
when we deal with column based data
structure
and within memory databases so in the
recent year another model called
vectorized production
became more popular here instead of
adding the whole row and sending it to
the tail of operators
we pick single column type read like
thousand values process them in tight
loop
and then send forward so this is much
more complex model
but you don't need to worry about it
because we took care of it we wrote the
entire runtime and bigquery
to use vectorized separators and we put
this new runtime
into bi engine so
there are a lot of benefits for cpu for
it first the cache locality is much
better because
you run very very localized loops
and you know second your code doesn't
jump around between operator to operator
so we can fill the cpu pipeline much
tighter
we also take advantage of modern cpu
instruction called
smg instructions which can process
many values at the same clock cycle and
so on
so get great benefits from it another
technique that we're using
is by using many different
encodings so we already
have support for a few encodings in our
storage system
but now that the data is in memory we
have the liberty of using many many more
because it's
much easier to change them in a memory
representation
i will touch couple of them here first
one
is the most well-known one is a
dictionary encoding
it works really well when you have table
with millions of rows
but certain column has only a few
distinct values
like maybe 100 or in this picture only
three
and the column is name of the song so
when you have complex expression
instead of computing it again and again
over each one of those
million values you just compute it over
the dictionary
and keep the result in this case you
know the result is boolean but it can be
a bit a type
now this is by the way an example of one
of the derived calculations that i
talked earlier when we talked about
memory manager
so the benefit is huge instead of doing
computation millions of times
we'll do it only three times dictionary
encoding can be used in
many other operators in aggregations and
joints and analytic functions
um so it's a great technique another
technique is run length encoding
so you can see example on the right here
it works really well when you have
same value in the column repeated many
times in a row so here we have example
with
quarters and we have quarter one three
times and quarter two four times
so again instead of computing the same
expression
three times we'll compute it once and
just say oh
and please keep this result three times
now we have dozens of different
encodings and they can stack one on top
of the other like you can use both
dictionary for example
and many others so again bi engine takes
care of
it all automatically it looks at the
data
it's statistics it clear history and
figures out
which encoding is going to be the best
so uh this is how we deal with cpu now
let's go
and talk how we deal with network how
can we eliminate network or reduce it
so the way we approach it is from the
clear planner perspective
basically we look at the query plans
that we
declare generates and most of those
plants are distributed plants
and then we say okay how we can improve
it given that we have this bi engine
with its stateful workers and
different scheduling policy and memory
data so let's again pick a couple of
examples
what you can see here is a very simple
aggregation query
and the distributed plan in the classic
bigquery will be two stages
first stage will do some filtering and
then do preliminary
aggregation until compute intermediate
results then we'll send them all over
the network to compute the final result
okay with bi engine
here's the plan with bi engine so it's
funny because it looks almost exactly
the same but
now instead of doing distributed plan
we're running parallel
plug basically our scheduler knows where
each piece of data resides on each
worker
can bundle them together and say run the
same plan but this time not over the
network
rent is a parallel plan okay do the slot
aggregation
locally and then also measure the result
also locally and now only after that you
can send it to the distributed execution
so network traffic
is reduced greatly let's look into
another little bit more complex example
so here we're talking about drones and
there are many drawing plans in bigquery
but one pretty popular one is called
broadcast join
it works very well when you have a big
table let's say a fact table
joining with a smaller one like
dimension table
so typical planning bigquery would be to
take this small table and broadcast
into all workers and broadcast goes over
the network
now what we can do is bi engine you know
memory manager can look into it and say
you know what this small table is small
enough
why don't i just duplicate it across all
of the
nodes which have the pieces of the fact
table
so it will use a little bit more memory
but now
join can happen completely locally right
we don't need to use network at all
okay so this kind of decision my manager
can do because it knows the reservation
size
it knows the clever workload so it can
do this kind of automatic tuning
okay so now we covered all three big
components of bigquery architecture and
talked a little bit how to improve each
one of them
and it's time to see this you know how
it actually works
we're going to show you three demos
we're starting with the first one
to demonstrate how bi engine handles
high concurrency
and this is artificial demo which we
simulated
and it simulates the following situation
let's say you have a company and you
have
you know table which is multi-million
rows table
in this example in this demo and
we'll have many business users and
analysts which need to work with this
data
so let's say they all have complex
dashboards and dashboards have many many
visual elements
so we simulated single dashboard
sends 10 different queries okay and
also said you know dashboards are not
static reports
people work with them so we said you
know what if
each one of those users changes
dashboard once every second you know i'm
gonna say you know this is
kind of very unrealistic nobody will
change it every second but we'll say
let's push it okay so many users
with dashboards each dashboard sends
query 10 queries every second
so what about looking here is a stack
driver
which captures few metrics first metric
we're going to focus on
in is this blue line which shows the
throughput
measured in qps and we can see
that we're starting with 100 qps which
roughly represents 10 users sending 10
queries
each every second all those queries are
completely randomly generated they are
not the same
you know there is no using same query
result
it's truly bi engine working full speed
100 a second actually 100 is too small
you know what
let's encase it to a thousand okay okay
you see
we're working with a thousand now it's
like 100 users
working with those dashboards let's ramp
it up
you know how high okay 2000 or 200 users
every second 10 players
system is working but now now how well
is it working
you know maybe it's falling apart so to
see how well systems scale
we would need to look into different
metric which is query response
matrix and you know you see those three
lines at the bottom of the chart
it's kind of hard to see because you
know they're
kind of very low so let's zoom in to
them
okay so those three lines represent
the percentiles of clear response
the lowest one which i think is orange
shows the 50th percentile
which is medium okay and then the next
one is red
it shows 95th percentile because it's
also very important to look at pay
latency
in large scale systems and finally the
blue
uh radar violet one is a 99 percentile
so first thing that we observe is no
matter
how far we ramp up our query load
they stand largely horizontal largely
the same
maybe at 2 000 qpsd in case but only a
tiny bit
also absolute times really good like
50th percentile is
only 35 milliseconds 95 percentile is
lower than 100 milliseconds and 99
percentile is
150 milliseconds remember this is
many many million rows table and
running at 2 000 qps um
you know two thousand classes every
second so we can see that
bi engine holds really well so that was
throughput demo and i'm passing it over
to vni to show two other demos
thank you mosha and as you saw how bi
engine is able to scale
much more higher to provide higher
concurrency now i want to introduce
madeline carlini who's a product manager
in tableau to showcase an initial
preview of how
tableau and bigquery bi engine works
together we're going to start off
in tableau desktop and the first thing
i'm going to do is i'm going to connect
to my google bigquery instance
then i can choose what data i want to
analyze today
to leverage bi engine all i need to do
is ensure i connect to the billing
project
where bi engine is enabled then i can
select the project
and data set where my table data lives
i'll then pull out the table or tables
that i want to analyze today
hopping into our first sheet i can pull
out
the number of records field to quickly
see that we're working with a data set
of over 87 million rows
that's a pretty hefty data set to work
with
now this data contains lots of customer
reviews
of various health and beauty products
sold by a company called
ylm i can use tableau to quickly
aggregate
the overall reviews for all of these
products
looking at the average review i can see
what of our products have scored very
high
and which ones haven't scored as high
tableau also makes it easy to quickly
switch between various visualization
types
let's call this product reviews
now each of these products lives in
various high different categories
tableau makes it very easy for me to
group these various categories
together into something we call a
hierarchy
i'm going to create a new hierarchy
called product
and by doing so it makes it easy for me
to drill up and down between various
levels of granularity
in my data now for this view i'd like to
get a sense of the overall quantity of
sales i have for each one of my
categories
i'd also like to add the context of the
average rating as well
now every time i use aggregate rating
here i'm typically going to want to look
at the average overall
so i'm going to set the default property
to use
average i also want to change
the color scheme as well i want to make
sure that i don't miss any of these
products that may have lower reviews
as i go through my analysis
now i can see that there are certain
product categories where i have a high
quantity of sales
but the aggregate rating isn't very high
and that might be something i want to
investigate
let's call this product
reviews and quantity
i'd also like to look at this data
geographically this data set already
includes state information so i can
simply drag state out onto the view
and tableau will plot that for me
now i can also add quantity as well so
we can see which states
have higher quantities sold
i'm going to add aggregate rating to the
view again
and i can see that generally the states
where i have higher numbers of sales
i also typically have better product
ratings
however there are some problem areas
that i may want to investigate
i can easily drill down to a lower level
of detail
to figure out if there are specific
cities where i have high quantity but
low ratings
let's bump up the size a little bit so
it's easier to see
we'll call this product ratings and
quantity by city
finally i want to pull together all of
these visualizations onto something we
call
a tableau dashboard using a dashboard
makes it easy to compare multiple
visualizations at the same time
it also gives me the ability to add
interactivity between these various
worksheets
doing so effectively creates an
interactive application that lets me
visually explore my data
i can look at some of our problem
subcategories
and select a particular region to
explore in more detail
and finally i can pinpoint exact
products
that have low reviews
and so with that in just a few minutes
we've built an interactive
dashboard on top of over 87 million rows
of data
thanks to bi engine now i can publish
this to tableau server or tableau online
and share it with other people
throughout my organization
thanks martline that was a great demo of
how tableau and behind work together now
i want to introduce
kevin mart who's a product manager
looker to talk about
how looker and bi engine work together
hi i'm kevin a product manager at looker
and i'll be showing you lookers
integration with bigquery's bi
engine first look there is a modern data
data analytics platform that operates in
database
this means that flickr does not ingest
your source data
so if you load a report or visualization
in looker a sql query is being sent
directly to your data warehouse and as
you can imagine having a very fast data
warehouse
means that you'll get a very good
experience in looker
so i'm in liquor is explore page which
allows business users to self-serve by
exploring their data building their own
visualizations and ultimately
answering their own questions the
explore page is powered by a looker's
modeling layer called look a mill which
provides an abstraction layer between
your database schema
and the business terms that your users
are familiar with
all i have to do to build a query here
is select dimensions and measures
and add filters say i want to know the
total revenue
you've ever made in our fictitious
e-commerce store
i can just click on the total sales
measure
and hit run myself behind the scenes
looker has generated a query a people
query for me
and has sent that to bigquery in this
case bi engine
and it's giving me the answer this case
9.6 million dollars
it's easy for me to add things like
filters say that i want to look at this
over some
constrained time frame i can click on
filter
i can pick you know any of these easy
point and click options i'll just pick
say april 2020
so starting on the first of
april and ending on
the first of may as i've done those
interactions with user interface again
looker is adapting to people
to reflect uh what i want so when i hit
run that's people get sent
to your bigquery's bi engine and the
result is posted here
great so in april 2020 my business made
441 thousand dollars
uh also if i jump over to the bigquery
console
we can take a look at those queries and
you just get a sense for how fast these
queries really are
i click on this you can see that that
query i just ran took
only a quarter of a second
now let's take a step further and maybe
i want to create a visualization
if i want to create a time series and do
that just by adding
the date dimension to my query again
hitting run
look at the jet adapted the sql
and the result is displayed here in
blocker's user interface
i want to visualize that i'm going to
open up the visualization
section where we have a myriad of
viz types in this case looker thinks
that a line chart is the best base of my
data
which i like and i'll go ahead and save
this to a dashboard
i have a nice little test dashboard i
added
i'll save it there and i'll pop that
open in my other tab
i'll go ahead and refresh this dashboard
just to rerun these queries again we
turned up all caching on this demo just
to
show off the query speed and bi engine i
think the dashboard is done rendering
already
at the bottom i can see my new tile i
actually added two from my previous
recording but pretend it's just one
dashboards and look are also designed to
be heavily interactive
so say that uh you know right now we're
looking at just
the data over facebook i can deselect
that selection
and that'll cross filter across all my
other
queries and i can see the data broadly
across all the
demographic profiles i can also adjust
filters
directly in the top that i want to look
at this specifically in some city
say you know san francisco where i live
i can start typing that in and locals
are offering suggestions
based on my underlying data
so i can click that bring in the
dashboard
and see how this is trending just in san
francisco
great that's it thank you very much
thanks kevin so in conclusion right bi
engine
is available today you can try it today
with data studio it's a ga product
it's available today but what we are
really showcasing here is
how bi engine sql api is
makes it possible to work to get the
same acceleration same benefits
with other bi tools including broker
tableau and other bi tools who work with
bitcoin directly so
that's coming some time end of this year
we'll have a initial preview
and also there are additional sessions
to learn more about if you want to know
about
how bigquery is evolving in other areas
there's a session to a da2n 200 which
talks about bigquery's roadmap
and if you want to learn about how
looker is evolving and with their
roadmap
their session d8239 so do watch out
and again thanks for joining